rapid number nine has always been for
many years now it's been that right it's
been everything that I do kayak and fall
that's really what it's all about you
know that that ride of emotions that you
experience as you take on this challenge
and arrive at the bottom and you've just
had the time of your life whilst being
somewhat terrified at the same time
ix is actually called by the commercial
rafting companies commercial suicide
actually all of the clients that come
down the river walk around number nine
it's it's what they would call a class
six rapid I would call it a number of
things the beating of a lifetime
now a rapid number nine has various
levels and particularly at the level
we've now seen it at surviving it has
every kind of difficult challenge that
you would want out of any rapid with way
more consequence than 90% of Rapids that
are run anywhere in the world
and so we really need to plan our line
it's not a matter of just floating in
and hoping for the best
there's distinct maneuvers that have to
be done first of all you have to
approach it from exactly the right place
now one thing you must remember when
you're sitting at water level in your
kayak as you approach a rapid you
actually can't see it is just a horizon
line and so you now you've got to make
some sort of guesstimate of where you
need to be finally it reveals itself and
then you start to drop in when you first
see that massive rapid number nine it
puts an immediate smile on your face the
problem with that going from a
constricted zone into a big open sort of
areas that you seeing massive boils
massive whirlpools and randomly breaking
waves this you know is some of the
biggest whitewater on the planet
now we were all the way left of the wave
train where we really needed to be
arrived because of the big hole down the
bottom there's this hole that just turns
into a whirlpool and watching these guys
go through and trying to get a shot my
heart was going and I saw them started
going left left left I was like oh I
couldn't imagine doing this right now
with my heart rate as high as it already
is I was saying to the guys that in
under no circumstances ever would you
take on that ferry above that hole but
there we were trying to bust that ferry
and so that's quite a bit of a coaster
to go through and into a ride at the end
to be excited and relieved at the same
time and together hey we made it you
just came through an ordeal